my openers Kelly Ryan text Liz as ran
away home and says holy [ __ ] she goes
the sound guy told me that uh Kanye was
here on Friday and I'm like I don't
believe you and then he goes on a
podcast yeah I think it's a Lex Friedman
podcast which I've never heard of I
listened in like six and a half minutes
in I see I see this clip I was in Oxnard
last night to see Anthony jeselnick I'm
doing interviews and I'm thinking I'm
funny and his opening joke
was so high level I realized that I
wasn't funny I realized that this dude
is a professional at what he does he got
dropped by everyone except Adidas and
then he does this interview where he
gives me my flowers and Adidas was like
that's too much you can't say the
anti-semitic stuff we're Adidas we can
handle it we're old school German but
even just don't like his flowers you got
it you gotta go it would be like if
someone was like hey Greg someone just
uh called you one of the greatest
football voices of our time uh it was
O.J Simpson like what do you do